Today I want to share with you how I
hash 200 chicks in a month as a small
scale farmer and I hope this video will
encourage someone out there who is just
about to lose hope. I'm Esa and the
channel name is Esafam and I'm from
Kenya, East Africa. Continue supporting
this channel and you'll be blessed.
Now this is my cook and a small scale
farmer. As you can see these are my
laying
hands. They are here and some of them
are there
up. These are the chickens that I use to
produce my eggs so that I can incubate
them and sell my chicks.
As you can see, they're not so many,
but they are enough for my incubator and
they are enough for my sheep. There are
several types of improved Kenya breeds.
We have like, ho, sasso and we have
raina and also we have curry. But for me
here, I have chickens. These are the
chickens that give me my eggs that I
incubate. I hatch over 200 sheets per
month and that is a good number
considering that I am just a small scale
farmer. And when I'm not hatching,
sometimes I can sell the eggs to the the
people who want to hatch.
Now, this is where I brewed my chicks.
And now, I want to take you through the
process of
incubation. How I start, how I place my
eggs in the
incubator. So, welcome as I show you the
whole process until day 21 when the
chicks are
hashed. Welcome.
I first start by collecting my eggs and
storing them well until they are enough
for my
incubator. And I incubate eggs that are
not more than 7 days for a good hatching
because more than 7 days their hatching
ability is low. That is why I prefer
eggs that are not more than 7 days.
After now collecting enough eggs for
incubation, now I select uh the good
ones like eggs with no cracks. I select
also broken
eggs and I I try to wipe the dirt ones
with a piece of clo and also look for
medium-sized eggs because sometimes
large eggs can not be cannot hatch
because most of the times it has a
double yolk and it cannot hatch. Also I
check whether it
has one side with a sharp pointed head
because the loud eggs they also don't
hatch. So you have to select that that
so that you get a good percentage of
chicks when they
hatch. After now I'm satisfied with my
eggs. I put them in my incubator.
My in cubet holds to 56
eggs. So you have to arrange them
uh pointing one
side like the way I'm doing
here. You have to make them uh to to
arrange them to point to one
side so that they can be able to hatch
well.
That is what I
do. I have an incubator with four
compartments. So I arrange them the way
they are. The same thing I'm arranging
here is what I'm going to do to the
other H compartments so that the eggs
can h face on one side.
You should not put h like some of them
are facing the the other side other
other eggs are facing the other side. So
they should face one side so that they
can hatch and you should keep you should
put only the ones that are going to be
enough in your incubator so that to give
space for turning the eggs.
Connect the wire to the motor and this
wire is the one that help to roll the
egg to turn the eggs. Then after you
have finished, make sure that you close
your incubator tightly so that the
temperatures and humidity escaped at the
right way. If you don't close your
incubator well, the problem might occur
during the incubation period period and
you won't get good number of
shakes. So be careful and close
tightly. Then you turn the upper cover
that has insulator that help the
incubtor to restore heat. In case of
blackout, the incubtor will still have
heat. Now you switch on your
incubtor and you need to set your
humidity and temperature as per your
incubtor. Now like this one, the first
day the temperature should be 38° C and
relative humidity
60%. From day 7 to 12, the temperature
should be 37.8°.
28° C and relative humidity
55%. Day 13 to 18 the temperature should
be
37.6° C and humidity should be
60 and 19 days after the temperature
should be
37.2° C and the relative humidity should
be 65. But all this depends with your
incubator. From day seven, this is the
time you need to do canding. And this is
checking whether the eggs has started
developing a
neo. And at this time, from day one to
day 18, the eggs will turn. But from day
19, remove your eggs from the rollers
and put them on the hatching trays. And
on day 21, hatching will start. and
you'll get your
cheeks. Now, this is how the incubtor
looks like when it is fully connected.
And you need to keep checking the
humidity and temperature according to
the days. And if the humidity is low,
you need to add water. And I add water
on the holes below to regulate the
temperature and humidity.
This is uh there is a way of measuring
water depending on the advice you get
from where you get your
incubtor. Uh this incubator is AC and
DC. Uh and that means it can use either
electricity or it can use solar
system. After 21 days, the the eggs are
hatched and you remove the chicks from
the incubator and transfer them to the
brooder where you keep them uh and brood
your cheeks with enough warmth and water
and also feeds for at least a month.
Then you can remove them and keep them
somewhere else to get enough space.
Sheets are so delicate and should be
handled with great care and especially
you supply them with enough heat. So in
a buda you should have a eat sauce. You
als you you can also use bulbs bros or
depending on your
choice. If I manage to sell my sheets at
day old they are more profitable. So
customers place orders and I hash for
them and I find this a good idea because
the expenses are
minimal. We have come to the end of our
video. I hope you have enjoyed the
video. Thank you so much for watching.
We appreciate you people for always
being with us. people from my country
Kenya, Uganda, Nigeria, South Africa,
United States, United
Kingdom, Zimbabwe and everybody who
support us. We salute all of you for
being part of us and the support you
give you are showing to this channel.
Thank you so much for the returning
subscribers. And if you are very new to
this channel, kindly subscribe, like,
and you can share to as many people as
you
can. Now we are on to one 10,000
subscribers. Let's meet in another video
and may God bless you.